Así que terminamos con un paisaje digital.
Esa creatividad realmente reprimida, inovación reprimida,
reprimió lo que nos hace más humanos.
Terminamos en las redes sociales.
¿Las redes sociales conectan a gente de manera nueva e interesante?
No, las redes sociales usan en realidad nuestros datos
para predecir nuestro comportamiento futuro
para cuando sea necesario, influir en nuestro comportamiento futuro.
Para que actuemos más de acuerdo con nuestros perfiles estadísticos.
La economía digital: ¿Le gusta la gente?
No, si se tiene un plan de negocios, ¿qué se supone que hay que hacer?
Desháganse de todas las personas.
Los humanos quieren atención médica, quieren dinero, quieren significado.
No se puede escalar con la gente.
(Risas)
Incluso nuestras aplicaciones digitales
no nos ayudan a formar ninguna relación o solidaridad.
Quiero decir, ¿dónde está el botón de la aplicación de viaje
para que los conductores hablen entre sí sobre sus condiciones de trabajo
o sindicalizarse?
Incluso nuestras herramientas de videoconferencia,
no nos permiten establecer una relación real.
Por buena que sea la resolución del video,
todavía no puedes ver si el iris de alguien se está abriendo para recibirte.
Todo lo que hemos hecho para establecer una buena relación
que hemos desarrollado a lo largo de cientos de miles de años de evolución,
no funcionan.
No puedes ver si la respiración de alguien se está sincronizando con la tuya.
Y las neuronas espejo nunca se disparan, la oxitocina nunca pasa por tu cuerpo,
nunca tienes esa experiencia de vinculación con el otro ser humano.
Y en cambio, te quedan como
"Bueno, estaban de acuerdo conmigo, pero ¿realmente lo estaban,
realmente me llegaron?"
Y no culpamos a la tecnología por esa falta de fidelidad.
Culparemos a la otra persona.
Incluso las tecnologías y las iniciativas digitales que tenemos
para promover a los humanos,
son intensamente antihumanos en el centro.
Piensen en el blockchain.
¿El blockchain está aquí para ayudarnos a tener una gran economía humanizada? No.
El blockchain no genera confianza entre los usuarios,
el blockchain simplemente sustituye la confianza en un nuevo,
de manera aún menos transparente.
O el movimiento del código,
quiero decir, la educación es genial, amamos la educación
y es una idea maravillosa
el querer que los niños obtengan empleos en el futuro digital,
Así que les enseñaremos el código ahora.
¿Pero desde cuándo se trata la educación de conseguir trabajo?
La educación no se trataba de conseguir trabajo.
La educación era una compensación por un trabajo bien hecho.
La idea de la educación pública
era para los mineros del carbón que todo el día trabajaban en las minas de carbón.
Luego volverían a casa y deberían tener la dignidad
para poder leer una novela y entenderla.
O la inteligencia para poder participar en la democracia.
Cuando la hacemos extensión del trabajo, ¿qué hacemos realmente?
Solo estamos dejando que las corporaciones
externalicen el coste de formación de sus trabajadores.
Y lo peor de todo es realmente el movimiento tecnológico humano.
Quiero decir, me encantan estos chicos, los antiguos que tomaban
Los algoritmos de las máquinas tragamonedas de Las Vegas y
los ponían en nuestro feed de redes sociales para que nos volviéramos adictos.
Ahora han visto el error
quieren hacer que la tecnología sea más humana.
Pero cuando escucho la expresión "tecnología humana",
pienso en gallinas sin jaula o algo así.
Vamos a ser tan humanos posible para ellos,
hasta que los llevemos al matadero.
Así que ahora dejarán que estas tecnologías sean lo más humanas posible,
siempre que extraigan suficientes datos y suficiente dinero de nosotros
para complacer a sus accionistas.
Mientras tanto, los accionistas, por su parte, solo están pensando,
"Necesito ganar suficiente dinero ahora, para poder aislarme
del mundo que estoy creando ganando dinero de esta manera".
(Risas)
No importa cuántas gafas VR se pongan en la cara
y cualquier mundo de fantasía en el que entren,
no pueden externalizar la esclavitud y la contaminación causada
a través de la fabricación del mismo dispositivo.
Me recuerda a los tontos de Thomas Jefferson.
Nos gusta pensar que él hizo el tonto
con el fin de ahorrar a sus esclavos todo el trabajo de llevar la comida
hasta el comedor para que la gente comiera.
Eso no era para lo que era, no era para los esclavos,
fue para Thomas Jefferson y sus invitados a la cena,
para no tener que ver al esclavo trayendo la comida.
La comida acaba de llegar mágicamente,
como si saliera de un replicador de "Start Trek".
Es parte de un espíritu que dice:
Los humanos son el problema y la tecnología es la solución.
Ya no podemos pensar de esa manera.
Hay que dejar de usar la tecnología para optimizar a los humanos para el mercado
y empezar a optimizar la tecnología para el futuro humano.
Pero ese es un argumento muy difícil de plantear en estos días,
porque los humanos no son seres populares.
Hablé de esto frente a una ambientalista el otro día,
y ella dijo: "¿Por qué defiendes a los humanos?
Los humanos destruyeron el planeta. Merecen extinguirse".
(Risas)
Incluso nuestros medios populares odian a los humanos.
Vean la televisión,
todos los programas de ciencia ficción son sobre
cómo los robots son mejores y más amables que las personas.
Incluso los shows de zombies, ¿de qué se trata cada show de zombies?
Alguna persona, mirando el horizonte a un zombie,
se acercan a la persona y ves la cara de la persona,
y Uds. saben lo que están pensando:
"¿Cuál es realmente la diferencia entre ese zombie y yo?
Él camina, yo camino.
Él come, yo como.
Él mata, yo mato".
Pero es un zombie.
Al menos eres consciente de ello.
Si realmente tenemos problemas para distinguirnos de los zombies,
tenemos un problema bastante grande.
(Risas)
Y ni siquiera me refiero a los transhumanistas.
Estuve en un panel con un transhumanista, y él hablaba sobre la singularidad.
"Pronto llegará el día,
cuando las computadoras sean más inteligentes que las personas".
Y la única opción para las personas en ese punto
es pasar el testigo evolutivo a nuestro sucesor
y desaparecer en el fondo.
En el mejor de los casos, suban su conciencia a un chip de silicona
y acepten su extinción".
(Risas)
Y dije, "No, los humanos son especiales.
Podemos abrazar la ambigüedad, entendemos la paradoja,
somos conscientes, raros, peculiares.
Debería haber un lugar para los humanos en el futuro digital".
Y él dijo: "Oh, Rushkoff,
solo lo dices porque eres un humano".
(Risas)
Como si fuera arrogancia.
Bien, estoy en el "Equipo humano".
Esa fue la idea original de la era digital.
Que ser humano es un deporte de equipo.
La evolución es un acto de colaboración.
Incluso los árboles en el bosque,
no todos compiten entre sí.
Están conectados con la vasta red de raíces y setas
que les permite comunicarse entre sí y pasar nutrientes de un lado a otro.
Si los humanos somos la especie más evolucionada,
es porque tenemos formas más evolucionadas de colaboración y comunicación.
Tenemos lenguaje
Tenemos tecnología.
Es gracioso, solía ser el tipo que hablaba del futuro digital
a personas que aún no habían experimentado nada digital.
Y ahora siento que soy el último
que recuerda cómo era la vida antes de la tecnología digital.
No se trata de rechazar lo digital o de rechazar lo tecnológico.
Es una cuestión de recuperar los valores que están en peligro de perderse
e incorporarlos en la infraestructura digital para el futuro.
Y eso no es ciencia espacial.
Es tan simple como hacer una red social
que en lugar de enseñarnos a ver a las personas como adversarios,
nos enseñe a ver a nuestros adversarios como personas.
Significa crear una economía que no favorezca un monopolio de plataforma
que quiere extraer todo el valor de personas y lugares,
sino uno que promueva la circulación de valor a través de una comunidad
y nos permita establecer cooperativas de plataforma
que distribuyan la propiedad lo más ampliamente posible.
Significa construir plataformas.
Eso no reprime nuestra creatividad y novedad en nombre de la predicción.
Pero en realidad promueve la creatividad y la novedad
para poder llegar a algunas de las soluciones
y salir realmente del lío en el que estamos,
en lugar de tratar de ganar suficiente dinero para aislarnos
del mundo que estamos creando,
¿Por qué no gastamos ese tiempo y energía haciendo del mundo un lugar?
De lo que no sentimos la necesidad de escapar.
No hay escape, solo una cosa está sucediendo aquí.
Por favor, no se vayan.
Únanse a nosotros.
Puede que no seamos perfectos,
pero pase lo que pase, al menos no estarán solos.
Únanse al "Equipo humano".
Encuentren a los otros.
Juntos, hagamos el futuro que siempre quisimos.
Y a esos multimillonarios técnicos que querían saber
cómo mantener el control de su fuerza de seguridad tras el apocalipsis,
¿saben qué les dije?
"Comiencen a tratar a las personas con amor y respeto ahora mismo.
Y tal vez no tengan apocalipsis del que preocuparte".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)